and jordan
do you think the problem comes from the
fact that
we don't believe in religion anymore and
if you don't believe in religion i don't
know who said this then you don't
believe you
people need to believe in something and
as a result what we've taken is identity
politics as a way to
belong to a group or do you think it's
far more complex than that
well there's a new testament doctrine
that you render unto caesar what is
caesar and unto god what is god's
and i actually think that's a very
astute psychological statement
and now it depends on whether or not you
believe that human beings have a
religious instinct
and i think broadly that the answer to
that
is that they do for a variety of reasons
first of all religious experience is
elicitable by biochemical means so
that's that's pretty powerful evidence
right there but
there are all sorts of religious like
experiences that we all pursue
so we feel awe to beauty we feel awe to
the ideal
we participate in like mass worship of
sports
prowess we like to see people hit the
target
which is the opposite of sin which means
to miss the target
we we get enraptured by a
gospel-oriented rock performance in a
stadium
and we do that with other people and it
and it fills us with enthusiasm which is
to be filled with god because
that's what enthusiasm means we
feel awe towards certain actions that
people undertake particularly if they're
radically altruistic or radically
truthful
we we're possessed by the desire to
mimic people that we see
act out an ideal that we don't
understand
etc etc like i've made a list of about
50 of these things that i'm not going to
go through all of them but
so imagine there's an instinct that
orients us towards the ideal and that
would be part of the consequence of us
having to emerge from this insufficient
biological substructure that heather was
talking about
and move towards whatever we could be we
need a vision of what that
is and i believe that vision is deeply
influenced by biological factors
reciprocity for example
which would emerge again from the
phenomena that
the social our social nature our
protracted
childhood dependence etc it's emergent
property of that all that
all of that is reflective of religious
instinct so now then you might pause it
societies have to organize themselves so
that that religious
instinct is fulfilled without it
disrupting other functions or without
other functions being disrupted by it so
the religious system collapses
well it doesn't the need for it doesn't
disappear and so then what happens as
far as i can tell is just
plummets down the value hierarchy until
it hits a point where it can find some
satisfaction so
politics becomes religion and then look
out
see you know maybe we have some sense of
an absolute idea we have the need for an
absolute ideal
and maybe you you make that abstract and
you you you view that as god and god is
distant and ineffable and
undefinable and abstract and eternal
he's not
local he's not local to your country and
your place like
like a figure like stalin or mao and
maybe if you don't have something to
project that ideal onto
something abstracted let's say and
perhaps even something communal
then it finds it it starts to
contaminate other
functions and i i believe that i think
this is where the new atheists went so
wrong
they assumed that if we just dispensed
with all that idiotic superstition
we'd all become you know avatars of
richard dawkins style logic
assuming we had the capability which we
generally don't and
i just don't see that that's true i i
don't see any evidence that that's the
case i think what happens is we become
we we we dispense with the catastrophic
superstition of
catholicism and end up swallowing
something
much more ungainly and horrible
jordan i i want to latch on to that
because we've been talking about
religion
and you know how we've turned our back
on religion
don't you think a lot of these crisis
has come from the fact that we
don't yet know in the west how to
address the issue of death
and you can see the way we dealt with
covid to me it seemed like a moral
crisis
it seemed like a general panic we don't
know how to address the fact that we're
mortal
and as a result of that we just seem to
be scrabbling around for anything don't
we
including identity politics well i think
there's some truth in that i mean
one of the existential facts that
compels us to ask religious questions
is the fact of death and so
and that's why i also think you can't
eradicate religion for that matter
because
what are you going to do you're going to
eradicate people's concern with death
i don't think so you know and i've been
at funerals and people stand around and
they don't know what to say
to each other not really maybe they can
give each other a hug that's something
isn't it
but they don't know what to say and
that's because we're all speechless in
the face of mortality
but that doesn't erase the question and
the question begs an answer what's it
all for
well we're trying to figure that out in
our collective religious ideation let's
say
so for example when i look at
christianity i think well at minimum
speaking as a psychologist the figure of
christ is the consequence of a
centuries-long millennial-long
discussion of what constitutes the ideal
human being now you might ask is it any
more than that
that would be a metaphysical question
but it's certainly at least
that and as that ideal
well have you got a better solution to
that problem
you know you think about how it's
expressed that that ideal is expressed
in music it's expressed in art it's
expressed in literature
it's expressed in architecture it's
expressed in dogma spiritual belief and
experience and commitment and faith all
of that
it's a very multi-dimensional conception
and you know you can you can
dispense with it rationally but
well then what you got something better
well no you don't you have something
that looks like a set of arbitrary
axiomatic assumptions that are enforced
by fiat
and and that's that's not a like part of
christianity
let's say was an exploration of what the
ideal was there was at least that
exploratory element
i mean i know things degenerate into
insistence but it wasn't
you really think all of that was
insistence by force
i don't think that's a plausible
explanation in the least i mean christ
isn't the sort of character that a
power-hungry maniac would dream up to
exercise arbitrary control over a docile
population it's just
that just doesn't make sense i'm going
to give our ancestors and us more credit
than that you know we were
at least trying to figure out how to be
ideally in the face of our catastrophic
morality
and that question that's not going away